it's it's only men only win three  percent of alimony cases and depending  on where you are South Africa it's 50 50  split is it really that's interesting  now you have to doesn't matter who the  money is when you are married it's 50  50. right so uh the stats that like the  the places I'm talking about is  typically the West so I don't I don't  I'm not going to pretend I know anything  about South Africa I don't but like the  point is that men typically face  consequences for their actions on top of  that there are women's shelters  there's not men's shelters not really  not at the same rate there's women's  shelters there's there's women's  empowerment there's not men's  empowerment